oh I saw Prince Harry and Megan they
left and if you don't know about it then
you can know about it right now Prince
Harry and Megan left and that's so wild
bye if I was a prince would I just they
gave up the titles kind of and they
moved to Canada and America been even
really roughing it do you want to rough
it give up the titles move to Serbia and
Montenegro dog you know you want to
rough it move to UM you know st. Louis
and Afghanistan you know but giving up
the titles would you give up the titles
the titles are kind of old-fashioned I
guess I mean I think that some of the
thing is crazy I mean I don't know I
don't know man I got a lot of schools
sometimes I wish we had a king you know
I wish we just voted then we just had
this kind of strange dude wandering
around in a building somewhere you know
in practice and jousting is [ __ ] like
that and doing thumbs-up or thumbs-down
every time I knew bad boys movie comes
out so you know if you have to see it or
not and then they you know but yeah
they're giving up the titles man if I
was a prince would I give that up but
Harry was the Wild Harry was always the
wild one he was in the military he
seemed like the cool cat you know he had
his wiener out in Vegas dude that's a
regular guy I mean hell he could be
President next you know in two terms it
makes you kind of the lady they got the
baby yeah I'm saying if you're gonna
give up the titles oh they're gonna
still be I think
kind of just didn't want to live at the
house that's what it sounds like they
wanted to get out of London they wanted
to get into maybe something just more of
an adventure kind of and plus his
brother Charlie is the yeah Harry's the
Duke I think yeah the other boys that
were going to be the King dude if my
brother's gonna be the King bro you
guarantee I'll be out fishing dude dang
bruh I ain't just gonna hang out at the
house and watch my brother be king yeah
boy dude I'll grow my arms out and be
out there chase him huh
you know or I would arm dude my
brother's a king I would be up to no
good I would get some neck tattoos and
probably get a Dodge Charger and drive
past the middle score that you are the
scene or the high school even though I'm
too old to be there and floor it and
make the ladies hot bro let the ladies
get that damp canal bro let him tighten
up when they see daddy roll by if I was
like very young I'm gonna talk about now
I'm saying if I was a young I don't know
what I'm talking about thank you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip then you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this cuz this
is alarming